i have to ask you about the morgan
freeman project the district six yeah
because i saw some did have you you've
obviously met him
because you have this project
the the listen well actually oh my lord
and brandt it's
wild to know that
i and i'm gonna geek out
man i have to geek out so it's wild to
know
you know you have this idea and it's
about your community and your people and
it's about like
history and like a place where your
mother grew up
and
you write it down
seven years ago
and then you just keep telling the story
telling the story and
then you go to morgan freeman's
production company and they're like we
love it
like eight years later working with it
with my with my partner who's irish
adrian adrian cunningham from vancouver
see look at your accent hello adrian
cunningham from vancouver
um so
well he's from dublin actually um so
but him and i you know this irish and
south african kind of coming together
and
it was
it's wonderful we are in where we're at
right now is we found a writer
you you've got projects like in
development you know what this process
is like right i have full respect for it
it's tough man i have so many projects
that i just love and i'm like why isn't
this selling or why is this taking so
long or yours you don't get it and you
just go hey man you do this because you
love it and if something happens with it
yeah
so it's very personal story it's never
been told before it's actually the the
area that it takes place in district 6
is what the movie district 9 was based
on
um
but it's but what we're leaning into and
it is said and you know apartheid but
what we're really leaning into is the
joy that people had despite what was
happening around them
so i think we've you know especially
these last two years you've seen a lot
of trauma porn tv that's it's just too
much it's like dwight i think ted lasso
has done so well you know it's just like
a really inspiring heartfelt
show that's funny and it's good makes
you feel good right you know um i mean
people say that i have to see it you
watch it [ __ ] do you like football
jesus like real football where you use
your feet
sure sure
come on no i guess i do i mean i do i
like i like sports i'll check it out
yeah it's funny um
and
but yeah so we're leaning more
you know into that and telling
you know stories from africa that are
not just depressing like we're just
as a continent we're more than that
we're more than famine and poverty and
war and like it's a beautifully rich
continent that has many different
countries
with many different cultures